[Music]
everybody is Charlie big news today is
they made a bunch of announcements about
what's going on with DC TV this fall
they announced when the big four night
crossover is going to happen it's a
prize surprise it's going to be a two
night crossover so I'll explain what's
going on it's still four hours of
television they released some details
about each of the big shows that are
happening so we'll say there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
leave a comment on this video we're
still a ways off from everything
dropping in October but they have the
tcas which is basically like a press
tour what do they say hey these are all
our new shows coming these are some of
the big moves we're making the CW did
that this morning where they confirmed
that the two night now crossover is
going to start Monday November 27th
which is basically the week that it
happened last year so it'll be Supergirl
first
then it'll be arrow then on Tuesday like
that next night it'll be flash and
legends of tomorrow so you still have
all four shows but they're cramming it
into two nights the episode of Supergirl
is going to be a legit part of the
crossover and even though they didn't
spoil what the story's going to be Grant
Gustin
did say that they keep going back to
crisis on Infinite Earths they're like
we don't talk about it all the time but
we're always trying to build up to that
so that's not what I think they're doing
I actually think that he was talking
about that in reference to the flash
vanishes in crisis newspaper that we saw
during season one that's meant to be
their crisis on Infinite Earths moment
so he said season 10 of the flash like
we know whatever the final season is
that's when that moment will happen so
if you're wondering if they're ever
going to do a legit crisis crossover
that's what it's going to be so that
means like the next couple of years of
crossovers they're not going to touch
that kind of stuff it'll be something
different
I know you're like wait a minute what's
up with arrow isn't it supposed to be on
Thursday nights that is correct
arrow is a Thursday night 9:00 p.m. show
for all of this season it's only that
one episode that's going to be different
so don't worry about it now it's so far
off you guys are totally going to forget
about it till we get to November and
you'll be like oh wait a minute arrows
on Monday night now because of the
crossover still no confirmation on what
the story of the crossover is going to
be or who the big villain is
remember they tend to make it relatively
standalone so if you don't watch
Supergirl and you watch the crossover
you'll be able to follow it you won't
have to know anything about the villain
of Supergirl or if you don't watch arrow
or one of the other shows you'll still
be able to understand the story so it
will start and finish during those four
episodes of television they did a little
more press about each of the new seasons
just confirming that they think they're
done with speedster villains on the
flash now when I say that that doesn't
mean that the evil speedsters won't come
back
they're just talking about building an
entire season around a single evil
speedster likes avatar or zoom or even
the reverse-flash which is kind of a
bummer because I like some of those
characters but it just means that when
they do bring those characters back they
won't be the main villains so you might
see zoom pop up as a hallucination in
Barry's head because the ones that we
know the hunter zolomon was basically
vaporized at the end of season 3 in the
reverse flash is still stuck in the
Speed Force so all those people will
come back in various different ways
it's a sci-fi spin on a TV show so dead
is not equal dead but they haven't
confirmed when some of those characters
are coming back they're mostly focusing
on the new characters are introducing in
season 4 so we'll meet the thinker we'll
learn about how he's going to work how
he's going to be challenging Barry in
different ways now I talked a little bit
about the comic book storylines that
introduced him it was a Wally West story
so I'll link that video at the end of
this but the other funny thing is they
said that they're going back to the tone
the vibe if you want to make a really
on-the-nose joke about it of season 1 &
2 so the flash is supposed to be way
more fun just in general as a TV show
this season so if you like the way Barry
was in the first couple of seasons he's
going to be a little bit more like that
it is mostly to do with the character
interactions like he won't start jumping
down Wally's throat when he makes
mistakes like he was during season 3
he's not going to be super emo anymore
so I feel like these are all good things
that's kind of what they said before
arrow season 5 after season 4 that like
okay we're going to go back to the
drawing board but every time I go to
flash John Diggle gets to be light and
it's actually a lighter it's actually a
lighter atmosphere where flash always
teasin because there's bright light it
I think I think there's like go to jail
and every light is like a brighter jail
everyone's smiling everyone's happy like
KJ you also probably saw that they
confirmed the elongated man is going to
be introduced on the flash they
announced the casting before they
started shooting Episode four so that
might be the episode where they
introduced him but they haven't
confirmed that yet
they've only said that they're bringing
him on it'll be during the first half of
the season and he'll be a relatively big
character I've already done a couple
videos about him so if you haven't seen
those you can just scan through my flash
playlist when I link those videos at the
end of this I know you have all kinds of
questions about what's going on with
Caitlin did they abandon the killer
frost storyline I don't think that's the
case I think a lot of that season 4
trailer is misleading I'll link that
video at the end of this tooth just so
you can re-watch it because half of it
is footage from last season because
they've only been filming for a couple
weeks when they did that but there will
be some new promos for that in the next
couple of weeks I know I haven't done
trailer videos for legends or Supergirl
yet but basically like the villain they
introduced in the legends trailer is the
modern version of vixens sister welcome
to the greatest show on a bullet for
bringing the circus to justice
well you three released a giant
saber-toothed tiger we're gonna need a
shrink ray ray I'm not particularly fond
of that name I've been hiding something
from us
they're the greater evil coming tell me
what was faith in you you and your sorry
excuse for a team could never handle it
welcome back Kulak so we met a vixen
during arrow season for her grandmother
was the earlier person to wear the
mantle she became the vixen of legends
of tomorrow season two so one of the
villains of legend season 3 is going to
be her granddaughter but she's not the
only villain she's just the one that we
saw in the trailer
this is PT Barnum played by Billy Zane
so there's another Titanic reunion I'm
sure there'll be plenty of jokes for
that in as for Supergirl this is the
raine character this is what she looks
like in the comics the TV show seems
like it's going to use her like an
alternate version of Supergirl with the
same types of powers but it's a little
bit different in the comics and you all
probably saw Erica Durance who's playing
a version of Cara's mother we'll see how
they incorporate her but it's just
another Smallville character that's
making the jump to the CW DC TV universe
so we'll see how long it takes Tom
Welling to cross over but he's going to
be on Lucifer this season but that's not
really DC TV so just leave all your
bonus video requests in the comments
below they'll be it more trailers for
the first episode of all these shows in
the next month or so but it's not going
to be a little while but if there is
anything for behind the scenes that's
really cool I'll totally do a video for
it congratulations to the latest
giveaway winner arc warriors please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so I can get your contact
details while you wait for everything
click here for the flash season 4
trailer again and you can click here to
learn all about the thinker in the
comics thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
you